>> SCHWARZ: All right. Well, let's get started.
Hi everyone I'm Don Schwarz. This is Toby
Reyelts. And we're here today to talk to you
about Java support for App Engine. So, the
goal here is really to bring you up to speed
for all of the new features and improvements
that we've made over the--little over a year
since we launched Java support. Before we
get started, I just want to remind everyone
that you can go to this URL and view live
session notes and you can ask and vote on
questions on Google Wave. All right, so here's
what you can expect from our talk today. We're
going to start with just some quick statistics,
a quick over view of how we've grown over
the course of the year. And then we're going
to spend most of the time doing a demo and
introducing a demo and doing a deep dive into
the code after you guys see it. And then we'll
talk about some additional improvements we
made including some behind the scenes up--improvements
to performance and compatibility. So we now
host over 100,000 Java applications on App
Engine. So this is primarily web apps but
we also have backends for Android and iPhone
apps. We have OpenSocial apps, Facebook apps,
Wave Robots, Chat Bots, et cetera. And that's
approximately one third of all App Engine
apps. So, you know, I think that's pretty
good evidence that when you consider that
Python had--about a year had start on us,
both languages are very important to us and
grow it at a pretty steady rate. We serve
thousands of hits per second in a pretty much
steady state. But we also have a number of
applications with very spiky traffic patterns.
So, the example you see here is something
called Gigya Socialize which is something
we've highlighted on our blog in the past
and they do basically a chat service that
is often advertised in television advertisements.
So, they have very spiky traffic. I mean,
what you see here is actually a graph taken
from their admin console that shows them ramping
from basically no traffic up to about 1,600
hits per second over the course in just an
hour or two. So, you know, I think that's
really good evidence that we can absorb large
traffic spikes on your behalf which is one
of the big benefits of App Engine.
>> REYELTS: So, Don and I spent--is this thing
on? There we go. So, Don and I spend a lot
time trying to figure out, what was the best
way to introduce all of these new features
that have kind of accumulated in App Engine
over the last year. And one thing we learn
from our session--our I/O session last year
was that people really enjoy, you know, good
fun demos and getting deep into the code of
those demos. So, we decided, you know, why
mess with success? So, we're going to do the
same thing this year. We've got a game that
we're going to have you all hopefully participate
in if the Wi-Fi cooperates. And we're going
to take a deep dive into that code. So, let's
pull that up. We have Wave questions already.
So this is a game we like to call Dance Dance
Robot. And kind of the way this game works
is that, you have this Simon robot. It's kind
of a mix between Simon says and between memory.
And this robot, right over here, he makes
dance steps. He moves his limbs and your goal
as a player is to do--is to repeat the same
dance steps in the same order. As you can
see the URL--the URL here is "dance-dance-robot.appspot.com".
So, if I come in here, I'll just enter my
name and then join the game. So, when I do
that, it goes and it looks for a game. Looks
like a bunch of people have already joined
in with me. So, you can see that it dynamically
picks up other players. There are a max of
like eight players in the game. And so here,
the robot is doing its dance. So, I'll do
the dance too. And then if you do it right,
you get a happy robot and you get some points.
If you do it wrong, well we can kind--we can
kind of see Don up there. His robot's really
sad. Don didn't get the dance right. So, we'll
do a few more
of these rounds. One really cool thing about
this is, this is real-time push, what you're
seeing, right. As everybody else in the audience
and Don here and everybody is making their
moves, those moves are being broadcast to
everybody in the game. And some of you may
actually be playing the game and you're in
a different game, right, you'll see other
participants in the audience playing with
you. Oops. I wasn't paying attention. I just
missed that one too. As the rounds go on,
the game gets harder, we add more dance steps
and things like that go on. I'm really bad
at this. I cant--I can't play and talk at
the same time. I don't think I'm going to
win this. Looks like--looks like maybe Brandy
is going to beat us all. We actually tried
to set this up for the demos that only took
five rounds but I guess we didn't quiet get
that right either.
>> Anyone else can just to do it.
>> REYELTS: Yeah. Somebody else beat us to
it and started the 10-round game. So, you
just have to suffer through it. Sorry. I could
talk a little bit more about this actually.
So, Dance Dance Robot is actually GWT app,
a Google Web Toolkit app. And of course, the
back end is App Engine. And part of the push
API, I was talking about earlier, is a new
API that we've actually just released. In
fact, we just got it out to production servers
very, very recently. So, we were up to the
last minute making sure--making sure this
all would actually go for I/O. So I'm very
happy to see like alarms and bells and whistles
aren't going off here. We're almost done,
two more rounds. So, Don told me while I was--while
I was working on some of the icons, some of
that he had first come with, I drew the sad
robot, the sad android and he told me, man
that sad android doesn't look as it is sad,
it looks creepy. But we didn't have a lot
of time to change that unfortunately. We also
had a big--we had a big tiff with the android
guys, they were like, "Man, we love that.
You're using our android logo and that's really
awesome." But you cant call the game Dance
Dance droid because Lucas will get really
upset and you cant call a Dance Dance Android
because then our partners will get really
upset too. So, we lost two of our favorite
game names. All right, so, the 10 rounds are
over and you can see what happens at the end
of the these 10 rounds like the scores have
been calculating and everything like that.
And what's happening on the server is, we're
generating the award and so I got fifth place
which is not so great. You guys in the audience,
so, who--I think Britney was first place or
something like that. There we go, that was
our demo. And now, we'll actually jump into
the code for this. I'll take applause if anybody
wants to applause. Thank you very much. So,
like I was saying, this is a--this is a Google
Web Toolkit application. Actually, I take
it back. I'm going to jump in to slides first
and talk about the channel service. How about
that? And I'll give you guys just a little
bit more background. We'll talk about the
design and things like that first, that'll
be a better order, I think. So, here's the
game design. As I was saying, it's Google
Web Toolkit app. We actually use two transports
to talk--to talk to App Engine. The first
is, typical GWT RPC. And GWT RPC is just XML
HTTP request to the server. We make all our
outgoing request to the server via that transport.
The second transport is a channel service
and that's a new service I was talking about
that is a push-based service, so all of the
messages from App Engine that we want to push
to all of the different players during the
game that goes across the channel service.
Oops, wrong direction. So, on the back end
we make heavy use of the task queue service.
And the task queue service is--it's been around
for like six months or so new since last year
and basically what that lets us do is that--it
lets us run a lot of background game logic
asynchronously. So anytime in our code like
on the server where you would write code and
you would want to block for a response or
just wait. Instead we, you know, fire off
a task right, and do that in the background.
And then we make use of three different storage
services on the back end. So, there's a Datastore
and Memcache and Blobstore. And Datastore
and Memcache, we use the skies and tandem
which is typical, we store our games state
in their and then we cache it additionally
in memcache. We talked to the Datastore via
JDO. There are a lot of ways you can talk
to it, you know, JDO, JPA. There are like
three different third party libraries out
there that are pretty prominent like objectify
and simple DS and twig. We use HTTP sessions
and those--those are transparently backed
by both of those guys. And then--and then
there's Blobstore and the way we use that
is that, is that award certificate you saw
in the end was dynamically generated. So that's
kind of like a large image or a, you know,
a couple large images that we store and that
we store in Blobstore and then we dynamically
scale it to the size of your screen and render
the place and the player text over that in
Blobstores. So, in general, the point of Blobstores
that you can store, really large objects and,
you know, I receive them and serve them out.
So let me talk more about the channel service
since that's really like--a really new feature.
So its push messaging and it's over HTTP but
it's actually bidirectional. So, if you've
ever heard of like hanging gets or like a
comet or even like WebSockets is coming along,
right. You're pretty familiar with this style
of communication. In fact I think we have
plans to actually make the channel service
interrupt with WebSockets later. The way this
works on the server is we have a channel service
API and that allows you to send messages and
then you receive messages from clients in
a web hook. So, the same way that you would
get like email messages or that you'd receive
XMPP messages. You get those on the web hook
with the channel service too. On the client
side what we have is a JavaScript library.
And so, it's a web app, you take this JavaScript
library in your web app and has an API that
use. And it looks--it looks pretty similar
to the server API but instead of having a
web hook which doesn't make any sense in the
client, you have JavaScript call backs to
receive messages from the server. And finally,
the channel service is built on a Gmail chat
client which, you know, which runs Google--which
runs on Google talk and the benefit of that
is that you know, it's already scalable, it's
already well tested and so you're building,
you know, your code on services that have
been around for a while. So, here's the server
API with a funky identity comment. This is
what you had programmed to on the server side.
There are three basic functions here. The
first thing you would do to communicate with
clients is to create a channel. And you do
that by specifying a unique application key.
And that application key just--is just an
identifier, you come with that, identifies
that channel. Once you--once you passed that
in and you get a response, the service has
created a channel for you and it returns an
ID that is a client side channel ID. So that
ID is what you will pass to the client to
your JavaScript app, right. To have it connect
to the channel. After you've created the channel,
then you can send messages on the channel.
You pass the channel message object and the
constituent parts of this are the application
key that you specified to create the channel
in the first place. And then, and then the
actual message contents that you want to push
to the client. Now, the channel service only
let's you send strings directly, like UTF-8
encoded strings. So you can't by defaults
and vary--like send objects over the channel
service instead of string data. And finally,
you receive messages, like I said on a WebHook
in the channels server--for the channel service.
And what you have to do is you have to like
parse the data out of the HttpServletRequest.
Similar--again, similar to the way you would
do that for email or whatever, so that's what
the parse message function is for. Now, let's
talk something about the Client API. Like
I said before, it's an implemented in JavaScript,
but we also plan on providing Java wrapper
around that for Google Web Toolkit applications.
And here is some sample code of what--of what
the API looks like. First, you create a channel,
and you specify that channel ID that I talked
about that was return to you on the server.
So, you get a channel object back and then
you open that channel object, you get a socket.
And that socket is how you communicate on
that channel. There's an on Open-Callback,
that callback is called once the channel has
fully been established, once your communication
has been established there. So you can act
on it at that point. And then there's the
on message callback and that's called every
single time the server pushes, you know, pushes
a message to your client and the "event.data"
there is the string data for that message.
And then finally, sending a message is really
simple you just push a string in there and
then boom it goes to the server. I guess I
could have highlighted those since I was talking
about them. So the Task Queue Service, this
is kind of new. Like I said, it's about six
months old but we'll go quickly over some
of the features. It allows you to do work
in the background asynchronously and dynamically,
so instead of like--you can create like task
queues on the fly and tasks on the fly in
response to whatever. You can have up to 50
requests per second on tasks and--my direction
was wrong in that slide. This works on the
DevAppServer. This is fairly new. What you
are able to, is you're able to take--you're
able to schedule tasks like you would in a
real server, and it'll automatically execute
which is pretty nice. So you get the same
behavior as you would in prod. You are also
able to see the tasks and execute them manually,
and that will also help you out in your testing.
Something else that's also fairly new is that
tasks can participate in data storage transactions.
And so what this means is that when you go
to add a task in a queue, if you have it participating
in the transaction, then that task won't get
executed, for example, if the transaction
gets rolled back. Okay, so before we go and
talk about the Blobstore Service, let's dive
in to the code of the application that actually
makes use of the channel service. So, I talked
about being a GWT application. And we have
our RPC, our GWT RPC service right here, and
it's called the Game Service. And the Game
Service has a few methods. There was the original
login screen we saw, and then we have something
that's a confirm login. So after we've established
communication on our channel, then the client
confirms that they're ready to receive messages.
And then every time you take a step the client
makes a call to the server to let you know
that steps has been taken. So, let's dive
in to the implementation of login here. So,
you can see that we go in, reserve a game,
and then we're doing some work here with the
HTTP session and so on. And we're starting
a transaction and then adding you as a player
to the game. And let's get a little bit further
down here, so we can talk about the channel
service. So right here, we have a--just a
small little abstraction. We call the push
server. And if we follow into the create channel
call--and we pass a player in here. You can
see that we're just--we're just using the
same channel service API that went into the
slide just a moment ago, and calling that
create channel function. And we're just passing
in a key, that's the player key. So basically
each player gets their own channel, right.
So, that's all really pretty simple. And then
the channel ID that comes back from there
is returned from this function. And so if
we come back up, there it is again. And then
in our login results, what we do is we return
that channel ID. So these login results go
back to the client and the client has that
channel ID that it can establish communication
on. So if we--let's follow into the client
code and see its side of that. So this is
like the main classes. This is kind of--it's
the entry point for the GWT application. And
there is actually a fine game--a fine game
panel. And this is the login screen basically.
So, after login successfully happens, it calls
back into the main panel, and it calls this
login complete function. And we see the--basically,
about the first thing we do here is we create
a client side channel, right? And it's using
that channel ID that came from the login results
that was return from the server. So, this
API looks a little bit different from--we
saw that was a JavaScript API before, but
this is Java code. Well, let's dive into the
guts of this create channel call. So what's
going here is this is taking advantage of
GWT's JavaScript Native Interface functionality.
So this is a JavaScript right here, which
looks like the code we saw. It's just creating
a new channel and just passing in the ID.
And so, it's really just a thin wrapper. And
if we looked at the other classes related
to this like--let's see, like the socket listener,
and things like that. Well, socket listener
doesn't have any code. That's not useful.
But in general, all of these are just a really
thin wrapper around the JavaScript API, so
just straightforward. So, what we do here
on a "channel.open" is we're establishing
a communication. We're establishing communication
a socket when we pass in the socket listener.
And there are two callbacks on the socket
listener. The first is on open, here. And
the second is on message. And like we said
on open was a callback that occurred when
the channel communication was established.
So when we know that the channel is established,
we call an RPC to the server. This is the
confirm login, so we're making a callback
to the server letting it know, hey, the channel's
up. We're ready to receive messages from the
server, right. And then the server response,
and sends a--and sends us a bunch of messages
that tells us who's--which players are already
in the game. So that's what's going on right
there. And then on message, this is the other
callback that's called every single time the
server pushes a message to us, right? And
I talked about this--just being a string.
And we can see that that's what I'm receiving
here is a string. But we're doing something
pretty tricky and neat here, which is that
we're taking advantage of GWT serialization
to encode objects into strings. So, this is
a little bit of magic, a serialization stream
reader. There's a corresponding serialization
stream writer on the server side. And that
encodes the object into a string and then
we push that string on the channel API, and
then we decode it here. And so you can see
what we get beck is this message object. And
if we follow into the message objects, you
can see it has a--let me turn-on something
here, so you can see on the left-hand side;
auto-scroll--to source and from source. There
we go. So, you can see that there are actually
several different kinds of messages here and
these are all subtypes. And we get the correct,
you know, subtype that was serialized across
the channel. Somebody is trying to call us.
So, that's basically it for the channel service.
Let me go back to the slides here. I talked
about the Task Queue Service. So, I think
we're ready to talk about Blobstore.
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> REYELTS: Yes, let me do that. That's a
great idea. Before we go on to Blobstore,
let me go back into the IDE here and talk
a little bit about the code around the Task
Queue Service. So let's go back into the login,
the implementation of that login method. So
we saw here that we're creating a channel
and things like that. Well, here's--what Don
was saying is that deferred third party library,
called the deferred API. And this is the library
that's written by Vince Bonfanti, I hope I'm
not mangling his name, which simplifies a
lot of the Task Queue APIs. So if you're doing
some simple stuff with Task Queues, it's a
great API. We're actually considering it for
inclusion in the SDK. We'll have to do some
code review and some tweaks. And we found
some bugs along the way but we hope that it
will make it. So, if we follow through to
this API. We can see--we can see that's its
pretty simple here. There's a defer method
and you pass a task and some options. Well,
let's ignore the options for now. Those aren't
really important, but the way this works is
that deferrable is an interface which is the
single callback, do task. So, this is where
you would do work in your task, right. You
just implement this interface and you do your
work. And I can actually show you that. So
we have send new player as an example of a
deferrable. So, when we defer in the instance
of the send new player objects, Vince's library,
the deferred library does all the work of
actually creating a new task and adding it
on to the task queue and it actually like
ends up serializing these objects. Like it
ends up serializing the send new player object
in Memcache or even in the Datastore if necessary,
and then and then when the task executes on
the task queue, he calls back through to our
object and calls the do--in the do task method.
And so in here, you can see we're just getting
a list of all the players in the game and
then--and then just sending them--sending
a message out with those players. And then,
you know, we have a few more examples of those
tasks here. Like dance begin where we do significant
amount of work, and then and then the start
game task. I think that's a pretty good coverage
there. Oops.
>> SCHWARZ: I'll set you up the bomb. There
we go. Okay, so now let's talk a little bit
about the Blobstore Service. So Toby mentioned
earlier that the certificate image thing you
saw at the end was powered by Blobstore in
the image API. So, let's talk a little bit
more about what Blobstore is. I know a lot
of you are probably familiar with that. I
think we launched it back in December. But
it basically allows you to upload and stream
large files. So, in App Engine, we tend to
pass request and responses around as atomic
units, and that's one of the reasons that
those are limited to ten megabytes right now,
but we know that's on and off. We know occasionally
you need to be able to have your users upload
large files and to stream them back to users.
So we basically implemented a separate infrastructure
that handles streaming uploads and downloads
specifically tuned for large files. So the
way this works is that you get a one time
use URL for uploading and you just submit
an HTML form with file elements attached to
it, and we handle all of the upload and persistence
of that blob and tracking blobs over time.
And we give you a callback whenever a blob
is at and that contains a reference to that
blob. So once you have a reference, you can
either serve it back to users in a streaming
fashion or you can retrieve chunks of it a
time and process it within your application
code. And finally, the image of API has been
modified to take blobs as input data, so this
is very useful. For example, if you want users
to upload profile pictures, you know, they
may have just taken it off the digital camera
and not really of the sense for the fact that
it's a five megabyte image, this allows them
to upload it Blobstore and then you can still
thumbnail it down to a reasonable size for
storage in your application. So let's take
a quick look at the application code that
actually implements this. If we pull up--so,
before we actually started this demo, I uploaded
that initial template for the award certificate
at the end. That wasn't the one I was planning
to use to be honest, but it works. And so,
I upload it through this admin only JSP. You
can see here which is just really trivial.
All of this has an HTML form with the file
element, the one App Engine. A specific point
here is that we're making this create upload
URL API call to get the URL for it. And this
string we're passing here is the URL where
we want to receive our callback. So if we
take a look at the server that actually implements
that URL, you can see here that it's basically
just making another API call to get the uploaded
blobs, this is getting the reference to the
blobs from the callback. There was just one
of them attached to this name, and then we
basically have some boilerplate JDO code here
which attaches it to a JDO entity and persist
it to a Datastore. And then finally at the
end, it redirects you, you also have to redirect
at the end of the Blobstore callback. So,
in this case we redirect to the server that
actually provides that back to the users for
distinct purposes. But this is the same server
that's used to serve that in image up at the
very end of the game. So if we take a look
at that, sort of lift--it's basically very
simple, it's just querying that word object
back form JDO, it takes the blob reference
out of it, here, and makes it into something
the image servers knows about, and then it
makes a set of image API calls here. As we
can see that we're resizing the image to a
reasonable size, and then were compositing
some other images on top of it. And what those
other images actually are is the dynamic text
of your name and the place that you received.
Now, the image API doesn't support rendering
of text at least right now. So what we did
is we actually found an open source library
called light text, which is on Google code
hosting, that was actually--I don't know if
it was specifically written with App Engine
in mind but it's promoting that it's supported
on App Engine Java, and it emits a bitmap
images for the text which is something that
the image API supports as its input source.
So we were able to very simply render the
text into a bitmap and then composite that
directly on top of our word template. And
then at the very end we just stream the data
out to the user. It was just that simple to
build everything on the server side. Great.
Oh, and actually I can show you--I can just
show you what that looks like here. So this
was the server directly emitting an image
back to the browser, and it's pretty quick.
Okay, so, let's go back to the slides here.
So we also made a--rolled out a diagnostic
tool this year called App Stats, which makes
it very easy for you to profile API calls
that are used in your application. So later
in the talk we're going to talk a little bit
about loading requests and the work that we've
done to try to speed up loading requests.
But putting loading request aside, the majority
of your time, unless you're a very CPU intensive
application, is going to be spent in API calls,
so it's very important that you have transparency
into what API calls you're making and you
can make tweaks to them. In last year's talk,
I talk through the API calls that were involved--the
layers that were involved in an API call and
pointed out kind of the one central piece
that all API calls flow through is a class
called the API proxy. It will actually showed
you some sample code that installed in API
proxy delegate that gets a call back whenever
an API call occurs and can make--can basically
log data about it. Apps that's basically takes
this to a whole new level. We have a servlet
filter that's very easy to install which manages
an API proxy delegate for you. It does all
the hard work and it stores all the data to
memcache. And then we also provide a servlet
that takes that data out of memcache and renders
it in a nice graphical way. So, we actually
have apps that's installed on this game and
was running the whole time you guys were playing
it, maybe some of you are still playing it,
I'm not sure. But if we bring up the servlet
here for apps stats, we should be able to
go into one of these arbitrary requests and
see what it's doing. That one's not terribly
interesting. It's just to make query, but
most of this should be making several API
calls [INDISTINCT]. Yeah, okay, so there's
where you can see where we made two channel
API calls and then a task queue call at the
end. So you can see that in this case we spent
234 milliseconds out of 238 milliseconds in
API calls that's sort of improves the point
I was making. We also track the request and
response data and the call stack for each
of these API calls so you can get a little--dig
a little deeper and find out what's really
going on. Okay, so, that's it for the demo,
let's talk about some additional functionality
that we've had it over the course of the year.
We made a number of Datastore improvements
that--probably one of the biggest ones is
support for cursors which allow you to pick
up a query where you left off in the previous
request, so that makes it very easy to page
through large data sets across requests. As
part of this, we've dropped the thousand query
limit, so you can now--the only limit to how
much data you can query is your overall request
deadline. We had a bulk ID allocation which
makes it feasible to upload large interdependent
sets of data; our bulk imports will still
take advantage of that. We also allow you
to choose eventual consistency over strong
consistency for your queries. So if you can
tolerate still data, this allows you to have
faster and more reliable queries. We track
and store statistics about you're Datastores,
you're Datastore data. Primarily this is so
that we can give you more transparency in
your admin console and to where your storage
code is going. But you can also query these
things programmatically, so it's possible
to find out estimates of the total number
of entities in your data store in constant
time. And a huge number of JDO and JPA improvements.
If you tried it last year, and you ran into
this trouble, definitely try again it now,
it's come a long way. We've made a number
of improvements to the URLFetch API, deadlines
are now configurable. So, in addition to the
standard five second default deadline, you
can now increase it up to ten seconds and,
you know, in the future we hope to increase
that as well. And we added support for asynchronous
URLFetch API calls, so you can fetch up the
ten URLs in parallel. We don't give you callbacks
when they finish, what we do is we have this
future-based API that wraps around the eventual
result and you can either block or pull on
it. And the infrastructure for this is just
general infrastructure that works for all
APIs, but the URLFetch is the first API. We're
actually exposing this directly to user code,
but we expect to do that more in the future.
Last year, we talked about how App Engine
was especially well-suited for web applications,
but that we were going to add more support
for WebHooks to make it more powerful in the
future and we definitely kept that promise.
In addition to task queues, which we talked
about, we also have support for an XMPP APIs
so you can send and receive messages, you
can receive incoming email. And we're very
happy that the wave team provided a new API
which allows both active and passive wave
robots. And what that means for you is that
you can receive notification that that a wave
changed as a WebHook persist some data to
task queue to do a complex calculation offline
and then come back and update the original
wave once your calculation is complete. We
also added support for kind of first class
support for unit testing. So, we now have
an App Engine testing JAR that contains subset
of the DevAppServer basically just enough
functionality to discover API implementations
on the class path and route API calls through
to it. But it also contains a set of task
config classes that lets you configure each
API. So for example, we will disable disk
usage of the Datastore by default because,
you know, you don't generally want that in
a unit disk. If you want to know more about
this, Max Ross is doing a talk, I think, in
this room later today that's going to talk
about this thing in more detail, I believe.
Okay, so, now let's talk about some behind
the scenes performance optimizations we've
made. We know that loading requests are very
important. They're probably much more important
on App Engine than they would be in another
Java hosting environment where you're not
necessarily dynamically rebalancing and reloading
applications across many JBMs. And for that
reason, a lot of Java applications or Java
libraries aren't really optimized for load
startup time. But despite that we think we've
made a number of things that help apps across
the board and have really improve loading
request latency, and we have a lot additional
ideas for big improvements as well. So one
of the big things we rolled out this year
was precompilation, and we don't--we haven't
really talked about this much in the past,
but when you deploy bytecode on App Engine,
we need to process it; we need to be able
to look at that bite code and see what you're
doing. And we do this for a number of reasons,
but the biggest reason is to enable applications
or libraries that would otherwise not run
in our secured environment to run on App Engine.
And we need to maintain compatibility and
this is one of the ways that we do it. So
we used to do this dynamically when we would
load a class, we would immediately process
the bytecode; that contribute to some slowness
during loading requests. So since a couple
of SDK releases ago when we turn down precompilation
by default, what we basically do now is to
process all of that bytecode at deployment
time. So, this not only saves us time during
loading requests because if it's not work,
we do not have to then and don't have to do
redundantly. But it also gives us the opportunity
for more expensive optimizations. So, we're
experimenting with things like building stack
maps if your bytecode doesn't already have
it or building JAR indexes that map out how
your code is laid out across multiple files,
or even something as frivolous, changing the
compilation or--sorry, the compression level
of a JAR can have a big impact. So these are
things that we can--we now have an opportunity
to do behind the scenes as you deploy your
code. So how does this work? Well, the SDK
is already responsible for uploading a set
of application files and they're check sums
to the server, because the server needs to
know which files hasn't seen before and request
the actual contents from SDK. As part of this,
we also identify which files are likely to
contain bytecode, and we've break those into
chunks of roughly equal work and send those
chunks back to the SDK, then the SDK just
iterates through them sequentially compiling
them one at a time. So there's lots of opportunity
for more parallelization and improvements
here but, we just did something as simple
as possible. But one really interesting requirement
of precompilation is that we occasionally
need to reprocess the bytecode for all applications.
You know, for example, if there's some new
method that we need to be aware of or some
new optimization we want to roll out, we need
to process code for all 100,000 Java apps.
So you might think that that will be really
slow and a lot of work and slow down our release
cycle, but it turns out that we only need
to process each unique file once across all
apps, and luckily most--you know, many Java
apps shared most of the same java libraries,
so it's really not that much work. The last
time we had to do this, the total amount of
bytecode we processed was only about 35 Gigabytes,
which, you know, when you consider reusing
standard Google tools like MapReduce and stuff
is really not even enough data to register.
So here are some of the results of the precompilation.
What you see here is the loading or request
latency before and after we rolled out precompilation,
split up into a few different categories.
There's the time spent in application code,
there's the time spent in API calls, garbage
collection, hotspot compilation, and then
finally the red line of the end is bytecode
processing, which is what we are really targeting
here. And you can see that from most steps
and including a sample of [INDISTINCT] map
and a couple of real world apps that I grabbed
here. We completely eliminated bytecode processing,
which was about 30 % to 40 % of the overall
request time. For other apps like JRuby and
Rhino and similar dynamic languages, we didn't
eliminate it, we only reduced the bytecode
processing time. And the reason for that is
that these libraries like many Java libraries
now generate bytecode on the fly or instrument
bytecode. So we still need to be able to--to
do this processing of the bytecodes on the
fly. We can't predict every class that they're
going to try to load at deployment time. And
that's why you see there's still some red
at the end, after precompilation is enabled.
But at the very least we've eliminated all
the bytecode processing for the language run-time
itself and in a dependent libraries like as
[INDISTINCT], those sorts of libraries. So
it was still a big win all around.
>> REYELTS: So, hello. There we go. That's
not bad. So I'm going to talk about some of
the Reflection Optimizations that we--that
we made specifically. So we had a set of big
improvements that basically fell into two
categories. The first one is a caching access
checks and the second had to do with failures.
And so the deal with caching access checks
is that they--they turned out to be really
expensive. And the example I want to talk
about specifically is the sample grails app.
So what happened is a--is Graeme Rocher who
is like a Grails lead handed us the sample
grails app and he said, "You know, what can
I do to speed this up? Or what can you do
to speed this up?" And so we started doing
profiling on this app. And one of the things
we learned is that in the loading request
it was making 11,000 reflective calls. And
if you know anything about Java then you know
reflection is like pretty slow compared to
like normal method calls to begin with. And
as we look closer at that data, what we saw
was that 50% of those reflective calls were
actually only being made against three different
methods. And so the good thing about that
is--that means that we could put together
a cache that would cache the checks against
those methods. And it would be extremely effective
and it--it was and it turned out to be great.
In the second case, what we learn about failures
is that some--some reflective invocations
I just--they fail very slowly. They have to
go through a bunch of checks and as they go
down each check and you--and you do all this
passing, you can end up just doing a lot of
work, when it comes to failure. And an example
here is a--is a JRuby runtime. We've been
working a lot like Charles Nodder who is like
a JRuby lead. And help trying to help speed
up Ruby loading requests and what we found,
for example, is that there were cases where
it was making reflective calls like "set accessible"
against "object.finalize". And if you know--if
you remember "object.finalize", it's a protected
method on objects. So we don't let applications
grab that method and do stuff with that. But
the problem was--was that JRuby was doing
that hundreds and hundreds of times on startup.
It just would repeatedly fail over and over
again and not realize that it was doing that.
So there are few things that we could do on
our end to help tweak that. But working together
with--with Charles, we were actually able
to improve the JRuby runtime itself, so that
it doesn't do those failures both on--or off
App Engine. So, in general, with this performance
improvements we made, we were able to speed
up startup for 10--for--to make it about 10%
faster for most dynamic language runtimes.
So there's Groovy and JRuby. But there is
also Rhino and--and other runtimes like that.
Here's a graph of some of the performance
improvements we specifically made. You can
see that in some cases and some of the improvements
were modest, but in other cases like "callingstring.index"
reflectively, it was like an order of magnitude
improvement. And the--and yeah, so the gray
bar here--the gray bars are the old times
and the blue bars are the new times and these
times are actually microseconds. So, we're
optimizing on the microsecond level here,
to bring you faster startup times on App Engine.
And, yeah, you can see "set accessible", where
JRuby was doing a lot of calls faster. Here's
the second graph with some more times here,
and what I'd point out is--is one of these--we
couldn't like make the graph very well. We
could go like exponential or whatever, but
then things wouldn't look like right. Anyway,
we optimize something that was at--that took
20,000 microseconds all the way down to about
200. So that was a--that was two orders of
magnitude improvement, which is--which is
pretty--we're pretty happy about and it shows
up in the end. So let me talk more about future
performance improvements to App Engine that
we're working on right now. The first set
of improvements have to do with reducing I/O
latency. And--and which also translates to
API call latency too. So if you have like
really short fast API calls right now, there's--there's
almost like a constant overhead to those API
calls, in general. And so a memcache call
for example, might be a fast call. But due
to this I/O latency constant overhead it has
a pretty significant impact. So when we roll
out this change, you'll see for example memcache
calls improved in performance by a pretty
hefty percentage. And in general, any I/O
you're doing, will have less like latency
to it. Another thing we did is that we're
reducing the time spend in JIT and garbage
collection overall. And when I say reducing
it, what I really mean is that we're--we're
improving the parallelization of--were--of
that works such that it all happens concurrently
and therefore you spend less time blocking
in it. So the same amount of CPU time will
take place but it will be happening on more
processors and so therefore your app will
be loading and running faster for all intensive
purposes. The last improvement I'd like to
talk about are reserved instances. And like
Don mentioned before, we know that a lot--a
lot of people been having a pain with this
and the pain is typically for people who aren't
getting, you know, who are getting a lot of
traffic. But--but we know that there are a
lot people using App Engine that--that don't
get a lot of traffic and it's important to
help our customers out. And so we've been--we've
been working very hard and we have a plan.
Unfortunately, we can't quite give you all
the details about it, since we're still working
on it. But let me give you some of the highlights.
The first is that, yes, you will actually
be able to dedicate JVMs and yes that will
reduce your loading requests. The second thing
is--is that because you're dedicating a JVM
that means that JVM is going to be in memory
like all the time, right? And that--and that's
actually a cost to us. In general, we've tried
to make App Engine, fit the philosophy that
you only use--you only pay for what you use,
right? Well, in this case, you're using more
memory. So unfortunately, you'll have to pay
a little bit with that. But we are doing everything
to make those costs very reasonable and so
we hope to give you good details on that soon.
And then the third thing is that as we give
you the capability to dedicate, to reserve
this JVMs, what we're also going to do is
to improve the App Eng console to give you
greater visibility and to how App Engine is
actually spinning up and creating JVMs and
things like that for you. So you'll be able
to make good decision making around all of
this. So now we're done talking about performance
and I would like to talk some about compatibility
and how we've been improving that. If you've
been watching and been using App Engine, you'd
noticed that our top issue is over the last
year in terms of compatibility, in terms of
Jerry compatibility has been around XML. Everybody
uses lot of X ML on app engine apparently.
So we work very hard to--to bring those libraries,
and the good thing is that not only can you
now use all these built in XML libraries in
App Engine, you can actually even bring your
own. So, for example, if there's a newer version
of one of these third party libraries, then
typically those will work out of the box for
you. We also white-listed a few additional
classes that were causing problems with third
party libraries and then we white-listed a
lot of classes that were causing problems
in terms of serialization, which also improved
compatibility. Here's a slide that just list
all of these libraries and as far as we know
did not work a year ago and do now, and this
is far from exhaustive. We just wanted to
give some good examples of a lot of libraries
that are now compatible with App Engine and
how we're working hard to continue to improve
compatibility. And we'd like to take all the
credit for--for this, but the truth is--is
that in general, I would--I would imagine
that there are probably people on the audience
here who have done a lot of work, issuing
bug reports and talking to the people who
work on this libraries and maybe even submitting
patches. So what we'd really like to do is
give thanks to the open source community for
working very hard with us to make libraries
compatible with App Engine. Finally, I'd like
to talk about DevAppServer sandbox emulation
and it seems like a little odd slide to put
in with compatibility. But what this--what's
important about this is that as we improve
the emulation on the DevAppServer, and it
helps you feel confident. You don't have to
go up to the production server all the time
to make sure that your library is or are compatible
and whatnot. So we thought we'd talk a little
bit about that too. One new feature is that
we're doing very good at enforcing the whitelist
now. If you've been using app engine since
it started, there were--there are a lot of
classes that you could use in the DevAppServer
and there were--and you really had to take
your app into production to--to have any confidence
at all that you weren't using something that
you weren't supposed to, but--but that works
well no. We also in addition do better enforcement
around reflections. So some of the--so a lot
of the things that you can't get away with
on the app engine production environment,
you now can't get away with it on the DevAppServer.
And, in fact, we generally improved the stuff
so well that there are now very few complains
at all about any security differences between
the local and the production environments.
So let me talk a little bit about how we do
this. What we do, again, if you've been paying
very close attention, there's a little Java
agent flag that you now--that now get specified
with the DevAppServer. And what that is doing
is that is--that causes a JVM agent to be
loaded up with the DevAppServer and that JVM
agent then instruments all the bytecode coming
out--coming out of your web app. Similar to
how Don was talking about precompilation for
production. So you can kind of think of it
as like many precompilation for your DevAppServer
and it goes in and it injects little bytecode
hooks that, like, modify, like, effectively
the runtime and makes the app conform--conform
to this text. So that does mean the DevAppServer
is a perfect emulation? Unfortunately not,
there are--the Google production environment
is so different than the code that runs on
your local machine that we probably will never
have everything perfect. That means that,
you know, it's still a good idea to every
once in a while upload your, you know, your
app during development up to production and
see that things are behaving as you expect.
Then I guess that brings us to the end of
our talk. So here's a little resource slide
we want to point out that you can hit the
Dance Dance Robot demo and try it out for
yourself. If you didn't--if the Wi-Fi prevented
you from doing that today, the source code
is on code.google.com. We do want to let you
know that since features that you're using
are so new to App Engine they may be disabled
after the demo for a small period of time
which will bring down the App maybe for a
day or something like that. And I guess we're
ready to take questions.
>> Sir, yes. Can we start with--since there
was no one lined up, I'm going to start with
the moderator.
>> REYELTS: Sure.
>> And then we can...
>> Switch back and forth.
>> SCHWARZ: All right. So what's the new COMET
support in App Engine going to be like? How
do you build efficient applications with always
open COMET connections? I think we've answered
that throughout our talk. Do we want to say
anything else about it?
>> REYELTS: You can talk a little bit about
the efficiency but basically the idea is that
we already have infrastructure to do this.
So when you use Gmail and Google Talk or whatnot,
we've had to build a bunch of scalable, efficient
infrastructure. So you're piggybacking on
that with App Engine.
>> SCHWARZ: We should plug as much talk about
that.
So, there's a talk some time today, I think
it's immediately after this actually, that's
going to go on a lot more detail about this.
I don't know where it is or what about I think
it's immediately after this session. Sir?
>> Hi. So one of those guys who has a Grails
running on App Engine.
>> REYELTS: Yes. I'm sorry did you say Grails
App? Did I hear you correctly?
>> Yes.
>> REYELTS: Okay.
>> And initialization is basically killing
us it doesn't run as a result. So I wanted
to know what are the plans to optimize it
more and also that would be very, very helpful,
I guess, that, you know, what you can share
and to make it actually work on App Engine
and anything else that you can share with
us now, please.
>> SCHWARZ: Okay. Well, so first of all you
want to make sure that that you're using precompilation,
so that's on by default. We're still constantly
making changes in the background and it is--this
is considered kind of best effort thing. So
occasionally precompilation wont' always take
effect. But you want to make sure--if you
can get in touch with us if you want us to
give you more information about your application
like the breakdown you saw on that graph earlier
of GC versus hotspot versus whatever. We can
share some information about that. We've also
talk about some additional things beyond precompilation
that we were planning to do. Like increasing
the parallelization of garbage collection
and hotspot compilation, we think that will
be a pretty dramatic speed up maybe on par
with precompilation and the I/O changes--depending
on how much weight code you have, that maybe
very significant as well. So, like I said,
we definitely have some things queued up and
we--those are the short term things. We have
some very long term things queued up too that
we're not quite ready to talk about yet. So
it will keep improving that sort of one branch.
And then parallel to that we are introducing
improved--reserved instances as kind of a
hatch, right? If, you know, if its performance
still isn't where you want it to be, then
our reserved instances let you pay for the
privileged of not having to pay that cost,
obviously.
>> REYELTS: Go ahead.
>> So it's just--you were talking about the
things you can do on the DevApp server to
try to create a similar environment to production
changes to the bicode. Is that for only Java
class files that are sitting or could that
also affect the co-generation that happens?
>> REYELTS: That should work for anything.
So if you're running a Rhino or Ruby or whatever
they all end up as bicode in the VM. So we
all--that's the awesome thing about the JVM,
right? You have all these different languages
and if you--if you operate at bicode level
then things pretty much are great.
>> Okay. And it seems--one another question,
I was curious--were talking about precompilation
is going to work for these classes that you
said, you have a JAR file that does a bunch
of work [INDISTINCT] could help of that if
you're using Rhino or JRuby or some of the
language that has a big [INDISTINCT] during
generation, that's not going to take advantage
of that. Are some of this other languages
looking at ways to do ahead of time compiling
or is that always kind of a challenge with
different frameworks? In this case, generally,
how that works for...?
>> REYELTS: Yes. We can talk about that a
bit more but it depends a lot like you put
it out on the language runtime itself. Like,
for example, there Rhino has like both an
interpreted and JIT mode, right? And the JIT
mode is faster and helps us, like, produce
more bicodes and stuff like that. Actually,
Charles Nutter has been working very hard
to like produce--to provide AOT compiling,
ahead of time compiling for JRuby, that's
much more amendable to App Engine. Like right
now AOT compiling for JRuby just isn't great
it produces way, way, way more bicodes than
it ought to and things like that and the--so
I'm really excited to see how the progress
on that will come along for us.
>> SCHWARZ: Let's take a moderator question
and I'll get back to you. Official Scala support,
so we don't--we--I don't really know how to
answer that question. We do have Scala support;
I assumed what this is referring to is things
like Scala, Scala workers, and different aspects
of Scala.
>> REYELTS: Yes. I'm not sure. What we do,
what we do and what we have been talking about
are making other language runtimes that are
JBM languages more supported. So John has
actually been working on that, actually, several
people have been working on that. So we might
see, for example, maybe a Ruby runtime that
is actually a JVM runtime. We might see a
JavaScript runtime at some point. And so maybe
we'd do something with Scala with that too
and typically this runtimes don't vary a lot,
right, because they're all using the same
JVM backend. But there's like Polish and Finnish
that you can provide around that in terms
of like config files like Ruby prefers more
yUML like files or something like that. As
opposed to like, you know, "web.xml" and App
Engine "web.xml" files. So we don't have any
thing in the works planned right now for Scala
but really it has such great interop with
Java. I'm not sure what we would do to improve
it.
>> SCHWARZ: Yeah. All right.
>> I'd like a full fledge to the API like
Java 2D. What's the plan for that in the future?
>> SCHWARZ: We've given it a lot of thought.
I don't think that we've invested a ton of
effort into it currently. But it's definitely
something that we've thought very hard about.
>> REYELTS: Right. We wanted to, we want a
full fledge 2D API for App Engine and the--and
again like the problem with that there's just
tons of native code that is kind of that does
like a lot of things like it use, for example,
graphic strivers and things like that. And
so we have to be very careful to weave through
that to make sure that we're going to provide
something that's safe, right? Like for everyone
to use on App Engine and so--it's definitely
on our plate and we have taken--we've taken
like initial steps and prototypes towards
it and it definitely looks like there is a
lot of code that we can use that doesn't depend
upon native code. But it's just--it's a pretty
big effort. So the time--anytime for that
we don't want promise anything right now.
>> Hi. So, yesterday according to the announcement
about compatibility with VMware guys and with
Google Application Engine for business [INDISTINCT],
does it mean that you're going to create a
separate infrastructure because probably the
Spring guys and then the VMware guys are providing
support for [INDISTINCT] for example or for
hibernate sample or things like this which
are more complete Java runtime environment.
>> SCHWARZ: Yes. I don't really know how to
answer that question. So let me try and repeat
the question. The question was, with the partnerships
that we announced yesterday with the VMware
and Spring does that mean we will be supporting
things like hibernate? Is that basically your
question?
>> So the question is it going to be compatible,
really compatible between Google Application
Engine and so, for example, VM code?
>> SCHWARZ: Right. Okay. I don't actually;
I don't actually know how to answer that question
to be perfectly honest. I know that the Google
App for business sort of product is definitely
something that's going to be kind of compose
of features that will be added to App Engine
over time and it's just kind of way to tie
them all together and provide a single price
for them. But I don't know how that fits in
with the--there are all sort of stuffs talked
about yesterday with interoperability across
Clouds, to be honest I don't know the answer
to that.
>> REYELTS: Okay. Do you want to go ahead?
>> Yes. I'm actually looking at the managed
stock files form the App dashboard question
because I have the same question.
>> REYELTS: Is that--that's your question?
>> Yes. And basically, you know, when we first
did our requirements we did--and chose App
Engine we were just going to deploy the application
part of our company's material on there and
it's a premium model. So, a lot of marketing
material ended up in there too which they
want to change all the time and, you know,
I'm head of engineering, so we go through
smoke on staging, we go through smoke on debts,
and the marketing guys are like, "I just want
to change one file."
>> REYELTS: I guess the good news is that
right now that if you do change one file and
you redeploy your app that really only re-uploads
that one file; it won't reload all of the
files on your application. Like they--the
underlying way that works is we have a whole
bunch of secure hashing schemes we use, right?
And so we checked with the server, does this
file exist blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. So
it's not like--it's not really perfect, but
you should get fast deploys anyway, right?
You're really only uploading the content that
changed.
>> SCHWARZ: If you really do want a dynamically
like on the fly change this content, then--and
then you can think about making it part of
your application instead of a static resource,
right? You can upload it to Blobstore for
example or just if it's small enough upload
it to the Datastore and serve it dynamically.
>> REYELTS: Right. That's a really good point.
Like you actually have like CMS functionality,
right? It's different than just kind of that.
>> Yes. Absolutely. And this is kind of a
half way there kind of thing.
>> REYELTS: Okay.
>> Thanks.
>> SCHWARZ: Okay. So what in JEE6 is supported
currently or in the near future on App Engine?
So I--I'm definitely not an expert in EE 6.
I know some of the things that includes like
servlet 3.0 and I know it includes new versions
like JAX-WS and JAXP and all that stuff. I
don't know if any of those versions that are
new lined up with the versions we currently
support, I don't know that of the top of my
head. But I will say with respect to servlet
3.0 specifically, we have a guy who works
20% time on our project sometime and then
was actually on the servelet 3.0 spec committee.
So it's definitely something we're aware of
and we've talking to him occasionally about
what it's going to require on our part, and
it's something that we haven't begun on yet
but it's on the roadmap. It's definitely something
we're thinking about. Okay.
>> REYELTS: All right, I think we run out
of time here. Are we done?
>> SCHWARZ: Yeah. We're done.
>> REYELTS: Yeah. They're cutting us off.
So thank you everyone for coming to the presentation.
Hope you enjoyed it.